all right stefan hey how are you stefan
uh where'd you go where are you from
originally i'm from florida originally
what part
northwest of tampa anywhere up and down
19 basically
yeah
and uh tell me about your childhood you
had both your parents when you were
young uh i was
yeah as most people do i had both
parents when i was young
they split when i was about three years
old
and you stayed with my mother but my
dad's always been a huge part of my life
he's very loving supporting my mother it
was more uh chaotic if you will but i
lived with her uh most of my life how
would you describe your childhood
there was one point where i described it
as oh it's just you know it wasn't grave
it was like anybody else's but now i
realize there's like with some evolution
i realized there was definitely trauma
like i had a lot of trauma um
uh some sexual abuse um
uh
there was a lot of uh
not narcotics but like you know
substance abuse among my mother and my
stepfather my stepfather was uh abusive
but also like a big mentor
um
uh that makes sense and there's five
there's five of us there's five siblings
on my mother's side i'm the only child
on my dad's side so i'd adjust
juxtaposition of like the two
experiences um dads every other weekend
um mom's full-time
what kind of kid were you in high school
oh uh before i dropped out
um i was uh
lenky and awkward and bad skin and i was
self-loathing um and like kind of hips
you know a lot of like like indie pop
rock kind of that kind of deal um into
music
also industrial whatever just very new
music um and dramatic drama school like
drama class but i didn't actually ever
perform
for more than one play
and you didn't make it out of high
school i dropped out when i was 16
got my gd immediately started college
classes and did
basically
where did you go after 16 um i went to
drug school um it's a thing where you
just get high a lot and it becomes the
main part of your life so drugs started
for you at what age
probably 12 like i dabbled like with
some weed and then xanax and
alcohol and i was like 13. because of
your mom no it's because nobody else
other than my older sister probably my
older sister is like was it was a user
and um we were best friends and not that
time she was like treating me like an
[ __ ] but we are now best friends but
it was her she started she began she was
a catalyst in my drug use um but i still
it's not her fault we're all make our
own decisions
what drugs did you start with that's
what i said um uh weed then xanax and
alcohol um by the time i was 14 i was
ate ecstasy for the first time
and meth by 15
cocaine probably 16
opiates when i was probably 14 when i
started going to the dentist
um so going to the dentist have dental
work done and then opiates started and
then that was the you know downhill and
today you're using white
what's that today you use what who said
i use drugs um i
uh iv use crystal methamos mostly it
used to be heroin i've
transmitted or transitioned rather to uh
full-time fentanyl smoking um every 15
minutes preferably
uh uh crystal meth it comes and goes um
yeah that's what i do yeah and no crack
oh yeah once in a while maybe maybe like
once a month
but i'm one of the rare crack smokers
who can pass it up like i'll hit it once
i'm like no i'm good i don't need number
two
um which is not often so you're so
after your
teenage years you what what kind of
stuff you get into okay so i started
working a lot mostly as my stepdad that
was from 13 on a lot of trade work i
started working hospitality a little bit
with my sister she was server i was like
dishwasher and then uh this you know odd
jobs a little bit mostly trade work and
then by the time i went a 19 from 18 to
19 i got baker acted four times um i uh
was a full-time drug addict [ __ ]
crack binges the opiates all the time
roxy30 is worth my heart and soul
um
still not a little bit it is um and uh
but the drug use was very like it's very
um if you will like very normalized in
my head like it was very like it was it
was not it was innocent it wasn't didn't
seem like a bad thing between me my mom
and my sister the three of us would get
high together um but then
yeah that's the answer you wanted
and uh
your 20s you spent doing what
20s i spent doing i got clean i went to
rehab at 19. how old are you i'm 32 32.
um i so all my 20s i pretty much
virtually all my 20s i was in recovery
you're in program i was in the program
i got me i had a great life it was
beautiful i had great relationships
great jobs hospitality worked my way up
um from housekeeper to a assistant
manager of a boutique hotel but i
bartended full-time i was a great
bartender i returned from in south
florida and manhattan
san francisco
um but i relapsed at i relapsed at 24 i
believe
uh for like seven months that almost
ruined my life and i got back together
and then i uh relapsed again at 28 and
it
just you know went downhill i managed to
finish some goals and do some quite good
things in my life and i'm proud of him
but now i'm
miserable all the time you've been on
skid row for how long
i've been on skid row for
three or four months i've been
street homeless for a year i've been
homeless for two years about almost two
years street almost a full year and i've
gone across the country back and forth
at least twice what what brought you to
la
um this was the first city i came to
where i wasn't like oh i'm gonna go get
clean i'm going to rehab i just came out
here because my friend was like hey do
you wanna come stay with me so i came to
stay i stayed with him for two days and
i was on the streets after that because
not from him he told me he wanted me to
stay there but i am on the run all the
time i'm running away from something and
i just can't stay anywhere for any
length of time so i just constantly need
to leave so the streets are what called
me
that's interesting
have you ever seen a therapist
oh when i was young i was on adderall
when i was
from second grade or third grade maybe
fourth on so i was seeing a therapist
then i haven't seen a therapist since
but again i was in recovery for
four years twice so a total of eight
years all my twenties so i definitely
did a lot of self work and like looked
inward and like you know but it wasn't
with the therapist it was with another
recovering addict
but if there was something
that you suspect that you might be
running from what do you think that
might be
my mom died two years ago um
i'm sorry
i didn't i'm sorry
so you lost your mom i lost my mom
two years about two years ago um i was
living in san francisco at the time i
just moved i just ran away from la up
from manhattan which is where i moved
from after uh south florida when i got
my first and only arrest
knock on wood um
and uh i had graduated nursing school
and was
working full-time as a bartender making
great money i love that job i was there
for five years um uh
and then i was escorting part-time just
for fun because it was fun i made money
um and
i
so
tell me about escorting
um sex has always been my
i've been like a sex out of my entire
life um as long as i can remember i've
been like some kind of hidden sexual
[ __ ] so i think it was kind of apropos i
think i always knew i would use sex work
of some kind and it came into play when
i tried to sell drugs unsuccessfully i
was a terrible drug dealer
my best friend got busted like within a
week and i was like [ __ ] this how am i
gonna make extra money working full-time
mind you i just needed more money for my
drug use um i started escorting
um did that start for you
um i mean somebody yeah i knew a lot of
escorts i lived in south florida at fort
lauderdale i was like it's it's
abundant with uh sex workers so i'd one
tell me who i hung out with who i was
partying with
you are [ __ ] it's embarrassing to say
this now but he told me i was kobe beef
um he told me how it was go he told me
it was gonna be and he said i was um i
was a whatever other grade he told me i
was
a 450 caliber that's what he said those
are the words you're 450 an hour that's
what that's the words he said to me so i
was like
okay yeah yeah yeah yeah i am okay okay
so um
sex work in south florida and entails
what
um i was full-time i've paid escort
thank you very much i was not i didn't
have sexual ex he got paid for my time
if something happened then between us it
was two adults consenting to having an
um intimate moment male and male female
and male 1 oh all male all male 1 yeah
oh i i came out when i was 15.
i came out as soon as i was gay 15. i
didn't know i didn't know you were gay
yeah yeah
yeah i'm a lady
it's funny because on the outside in my
head i think i'm a lady i present like i
don't really think i'm a lady i'm not
like trans i just like i i think it's
obvious i'm gay like
but people often tell me oh i didn't
know you were gay like it's a compliment
not that you were doing that now that's
not what you're doing no i just but but
like i'm like it's not a compliment i
just am who i am and i'm gay and i'm
okay with it and if you have a problem
with it [ __ ] you um so that's how bad i
feel about that so i don't even think
that as an issue so that's why i just
didn't mention it yeah so so back to
like what you might be running from
oh oh dead mom um uh so the 10 years
that i was
clean i'll say not ten years eight years
so i was clean four and a half years and
three and a half years um i didn't talk
to my mother at all um
growing up she was like a boss like
woman she was up like somebody look up
to she was like it's a store manager of
like every possible story you'd think of
like target tj maxx oh should we edit
that out we can't say that i don't know
all these all these different stories
any man in her life except like maybe
one or two she made more money then she
was like but always working always
working overtime like
um
[Music]
i heard i heard i love you from both my
parents all the time like constantly
like it was my dad was like the most
important thing in the world my mom was
like i love you i love you i love you um
so we were really like close like i i
have that like affectionate personality
because of that and i i owe that to them
and i'm grateful for that um because it
makes me see the world in a way of like
i think everybody i literally have i
love you a tattoo to my chest like i
think everybody deserves like you know
we're all deserving of that um
sorry
i didn't talk to her 10 years because i
was like self-righteous and like i was
clean and i thought that i was like she
needed to get clean and she wouldn't
listen my older sister went to prison
i
19 i went to rehab because i was the bad
one because i kept trying to kill myself
older sister i got clean the two of them
went downhill started shooting up
uh sister went to prison found out
should have seen my mom had a pepsi my
little i have a little um 10 year
younger sister she's not little she's 23
now but um in my mind she's like you
know um so she had a very different
upbringing than we did because my mom
was like christmas was always awesome
like she worked like we had the best
stuff because she always worked at great
stores my little sister had this
terrible experience my mom was like
shooting up and like like a mess and
like she became this person different
person and i couldn't relate to her
anymore
so i didn't talk to her like the entire
time because i was clean
sorry that's really hard to talk about
so you're doing a great job
i didn't
so
didn't talk to my mom very little
cards birthday cards whatever i just
wouldn't really respond as much because
she wouldn't listen she was an addict i
knew she was an addict i just i knew
there was a better way because i was
happy
and
um
yeah i was happy and i was like
productive and i was like a productive
member of society like i like learn
self-esteem and like learn things about
myself that i wish that she could have
shared that she never could and my
sister got out of prison a couple times
moved in with me and like the second
time she finally got it together and
like the two of us were on top of the
world for a long time and my mom was
still smoking bath salts at some point i
had custody of my little sister for a
time
for a summer really not that long
um
my sister
then older sister got uh clean with me
and broke up with my boyfriend that i
had the time long term who was a great
love of my life still is i wish i had
kept that relationship
um he like held he was there with me
when i had custody my little sister like
she lived in a second bedroom like he
was like you know like what a what a
great [ __ ] burst into like you know
he he was the saint but anyways um
i uh got my broke up with him little
sister went home because my mom was
doing better um always just to move back
in got clean finally the two of us were
on top of the world and like that was
probably the best time of my life um
that from like that three and a half
years i was clean i got through nursing
school was on top of my class um
um and then i relapsed right before
spring break before my internship um and
i still managed to pass
barely
um i i um
passed my board didn't study because i
was getting high the whole time and
having a lot of random sex all with all
the random people because i'd not
experienced that as a teenage math user
i had experience out of a light bulb in
a pool behind trailer that's not really
the same as like like sex gay party
meth like that comes when you're older
and you look good um so
that came and i was like it was a whole
other story so the sex addiction
bloomed when i was sober because it was
hidden and it was with random people and
then bloomed again when i was on drugs
because
it wasn't hidden and it was with random
people and now that i'm a total fentanyl
user um i am asexual have no sex at all
so uh it's an odd place to be in um
question
so this is this the lowest point in your
life right now you think yeah yeah
you've been through a lot
what was the best time of your life
when those four years i was clean when
you were trying yeah right before
nursing school it was the best years of
my life
even any of the time i was clean anytime
that i was like working and cleaning
like making these relationships i had a
bartender i had a bar guest pay for me
to go to cuba with 30 people they were
all like musicians
oh you gave me just you only blindness
um it was all like broadway people and
like so he just picked like a random ass
bartender like who does that he had like
all we all went to havana stayed at like
the nicest hotel there which you know
compared to here is not that nice but
that's what it was lovely and he was
amazing experience he also gave me
tickets to go see hamilton he got
another
guest gave us first class um delta
tickets like i had a life that was like
it was [ __ ] cool like i worked really
hard for
everything i had i i worked from the
ground up
you know and i had a really great life i
looked good i was always working out i
was like 215 a muscle i was like [ __ ]
stacked but not in like a oh i'm better
than you but like a nice like
confident humble
nobody's humble when they say they're
humble but i really possess humility
because i remain teachable and like i
was a nice very i was really proud of
the person i was and now i'm like
desperately like hate myself like
self-loathing like all the time
and it's like it's really hard i
i wish i wanted to want to want to want
to want to get clean so hard so much but
like it's yeah it's just not happening
incredibly hard right oh just the
opiates in general incredibly hard the
crystal is hard too but in an insidious
way where because i don't seek that out
i never pay for that what about
something like suboxone something like
that um
suboxone it helps it's gotten me off
it's worked
last night i took it i went through
precipitated withdrawals and shot myself
outside of a walgreens an ambulance came
picking up in the middle of probably the
day like at two o'clock in the afternoon
it's quite quite in my hometown of
course of fort lauderdale um
yeah it was the most humiliating moment
of my life um uh but uh um besides that
time the suboxone were great
um
um uh
anyways
you have a sense of humor about it yeah
that's my number one rules like laugh
like
i've not i believe in like master's
hierarchy of needs and like i have
different ideas of like god and
spirituality
that's beside the point but like
laughter humor is the number one thing
for me it's at the peak like if you you
have to laugh at the end of the day like
i make everything a joke
you see what i'm saying you said it
helps keep you sane oh it helps keep me
sane yeah it helps keep things in keeps
my perception like
it's a joke dude like this is we're
living it's a joke we're all like we all
our egos are all so inflated we're
[ __ ] nothing on top of nothing on top
and we're nothing we're nothing and
everybody's so full of themselves like
it's not it's like i can have a
hedonistic point of view where nothing
matters but i could also feel like
like i like sarah silverman when she
says like like i can think like you you
[ __ ] with all your 500 bags but at
the same time i think i want to be on i
want to be on money like that same kind
of like i don't want to be on money but
i think that sense of like we the
juxtaposition again of like the back and
forth like we mean nothing but also like
i want to make a difference in the world
somehow yeah do you have friends at this
point um at this point
no friends i have i would say three
friends which is really kind of
two or three friends it's really a big
deal on the streets here in l.a that's
really surprising i've been the streets
literally everywhere so like i can name
them if you ask me i'll tell you i've
been there and i've know people there i
haven't had friends anywhere this is the
first time i've actually made like three
decent people um other than that but
clean stefan
[ __ ] i use my real name i go away steve
on the streets but stefan's my real name
um clean stefan um i uh um i have a
million people who i don't answer the
phone calls respond to them that love me
and that wish that i was like better and
like
you know
yeah i've like a load of like tons
there's tons there's like tons and tons
of people but not like like the close
like close meaningful relationships and
now i have nobody because i ignore
everybody all the time because i'm like
so stuck in my [ __ ] addiction yeah
a lot of shame i don't know
yeah you know
yeah
a lot of self-loathing
uh yeah i beat myself up a lot
you're staying in the street yeah you're
in a tent no
i don't have a tent i just try to stay
up all night and wander and try to sleep
in the morning i try to sleep in the
morning from five years from four to
noon when the train's open so you can
sleep and then until noon so a good
eight hours of sleep but on top of my
things
so nobody steals from me because when i
slept on the street i got pepper sprayed
and tried and robbed and
it's not fun um so that's where i'm at
right now how do you support your
software right now i just started
boosting which i'm actually pretty good
at um that hasn't lasted very long like
they just started i've always been
against stealing and selling it
defensively yeah yeah exactly
there's a place here in la that it's
like an abundance of that and it's
insane and it's got to end soon because
it's crazy these oh code's gonna end and
these idiots are gonna like it they're
gonna get reality check real quick
because they're just living this life
that's like it's insane the amount of
theft that happens here oh god if i'm
saying i'm gonna get shot somebody's
gonna kill me because i said that just
if that happens it's your fault just to
be clear um but yeah
everybody's doing it it's crazy so i got
now i dip my toe into it and i'm pretty
good and it works like i'm not so
relying on my [ __ ]
um unemployment money which is all legit
believe it or not because i've managed
to have jobs in my life um
but so that's is ending now which
reminds me i gotta file before too um
which relationship was more important to
you your relationship with your mom or
your dad oh they're equal um in
different ways i got different things
from different ones um again both very
loving parents my mom was bipolar
bipolar too she was hypomania
um we'd go through spurts of like we
need to move we moved a lot we always
moved we moved up and down 19
um from uh pinellas to pasco
getting far and far
getting more and more white trash as we
moved north um
but uh in high school i started riding
horses we bonded over that i started
riding horses i was really good at that
that was natural thing we did really
well and then her using really tore us
apart
and then whenever i relapsed we had a
brief moment of connection again
i started i got clean again we tore us
apart
and then my last
last six months she was alive
um she got hep c
this isn't my this isn't fair for me
this isn't fair for me to share this
because this is not my like but my
sister gave my mom hipstery when they're
sharing needles i think i mentioned that
so um that's actually what killed her
and uh you think i would have asked my
older my mom like hello hey how's your
liver um when i was a nurse in nursing
school but i never asked her about it
because we're all in denial that she had
it um my sister who was living with me
at the time i got cured she got on her
vote and he got cured in a month
my dad had went on interferon when i was
in middle school because he had hep c
from something like drug drug uh blood
transfusion back in the day so i've
everybody my everybody my family has had
a hep c except for my little sister and
now i too wouldn't have it after
two year anniversary of her death i
realized i was told by a doctor that i
had hep c2 which i knowingly shared
needles you know and i didn't really
care that's how i got it but um
yeah so that's what ended up killing her
um and i'm grateful for the last six
months she was alive because we got so
close again i was able to like let down
those walls and like realize she's the
same person and she's not just this like
junkie like she's still there and um
yeah like
we yeah like the last day i saw her live
like it was like beautiful it was like
yeah it was great but um i regret
the years of like ignoring like you know
like i was like not like
yeah so that's that's that um but the
last last day i saw her live was it was
serendipitous like it was like so it's
such a joke of how perfect it was it was
it was it was great i said everything
needed to say and she said what she
needed to say it was it was good
it's nice you had that yeah
what do you think keeps you stuck is it
is it the
the power of the addiction is it the
self
the first tendencies
sorry um go ahead is it is it what do
you think keeps you stuck
stuck now the first time i got clean
first time i relapsed and then i got
clean again
i went to her and i stayed with her for
one night literally one night and i like
would spend the time with her and
connected with her and then like i left
go get like get it together like you
talked about phone to my dad but i was
like get your life together you know i
went got my job back whatever this that
sorry about the ash um
[Music]
i like managing my life together kept
the boyfriend like [ __ ] did it this
time around i don't have anybody i don't
have a home to go to like i don't have
like a home to go like
like just have somebody just like take
care of me just for a night like i
literally just need like a night of like
somebody tell me like like in like in
like
yeah maybe maybe it also could just be
the drugs or that taken hold i'm older
now so like
everything i'm jaded so it's hard for me
to get back into the program because i'm
jaded like i did it twice like i did it
i've worked it twice where now i'm like
i hear people talk and i'm like oh god
like in the first time i was really
enthusiastic the second time around i
was like okay i know i need to do this
and it's good for me and this time like
the people i i had that strong
relationships with have all disowned me
like they don't talk to me and my old
old sponsor will talk to me and like
i just i feel alone you know i feel
alone all the time so the drugs are the
only thing that makes me feel like i'm
not alone
what's your biggest regret
using that second time
right before i graduated nursing school
that was my biggest regret i shouldn't i
would have i'd be on top of the world
right now if i hadn't like the world is
at my fingertips
the first time i relapsed it was i was
close to there and i was like doing well
the second time it was like really the
world was really really at my fingertips
like everything was right there all my
dreams were there and i and i like let
them all go
do you think you're
self-sabotaging oh yes i i see i see
i see everything like working out my
favorite like things almost become too
not too easy but like two like too good
like too good things are too good i must
find they're they're i really feel like
i've done a lot of work but i must do
something deeper that's like i haven't
there's something that makes me feel
like i don't deserve it because like
like i i self-sabotage like
everything was right there and i just
let it all go i think we all do it to
some extent yes but some of us are just
like interested as rupaul would say
sorry to interrupt you yeah
um
did you still have contact with your
with your family
oh
i talked to my sister a little bit my
little sister not so much she's doing
great though she invited me for
christmas asked me to stay
my older sister just had a kid and i
have a nephew who i've never met yet but
um it makes me really happy she's doing
dad is still around my dad is there he's
just retired he's still around he's
always helped me as much as ever could
he's never done much that makes a lot of
money he's like
worked as a like a head janitor
basically for
schools my entire life so he's made a
little bit of money but done everything
he could to help me my entire life so
he's still around yes but i just don't
ever talk to him because i'm ashamed
yeah it's it's a shame on your part not
not yeah i'm ashamed of myself that's
there
because right when i was graduating
nursing school like the look in his face
like
like that alone that could make me cry
again too because like the the pride
that he had of seeing me walk across
stage like that i did that that a high
school dropout i got
i have two associate degrees i don't
know i like to think that's a bachelor's
but it's not to associate degrees but i
am an rn um well it was until july when
my license expired but um
yeah the look of pride on his face he
was so proud and he would always tell me
how proud he was of me when i was doing
well and now it's like so i'm just i
just want you i know i don't i don't
want you to suffer anymore he's yeah
he's great he's i couldn't be luckier i
couldn't have a better dad
what uh what would you say is the most
important thing you've learned in your
life um the most important thing i
learned in my life um
humility integrity
integrity and
take nothing personal
yeah right stefan thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you
and i wish you the best of luck
yeah thank you
thank you very much
you